the thousands of gifts the hindu
community had donated for children and
adults across samwell will the prime
minister join me in thanking sever day
deepak mandu and reena who i'll be
joining again this friday at west
bromwich sri krishna mandir
[Applause]
yes i thank my i thank my honourable
friend for raising the work of sower day
and uh for all the people of west
bromwich uh hindu community who do make
an incredible contribution uh to this
country and i'm delighted that the
charity is again uh distributing donated
gifts thank you to everyone involved and
particularly to my honorable friend for
her efforts
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kia starbuck
thank you mr speaker can i also wish you
um everybody works in this house and all
members uh a merry christmas and a happy
new year
and can i also send my congratulations
to the prime minister and his wife on
the birth of their daughter and join the
prime minister in supporting our armed
forces and all those on the front line
mr speaker there were 200 000 omicron
infections on monday that's doubling
every two or three days
and the nhs could be overwhelmed
so i want to start by encouraging
everyone listening to this session to
get their jabs and boosters
it's the best way to protect themselves
the nhs and their loved ones
given the seriousness of the situation
does the prime minister agree that the
hundred conservative members who voted
against plan b measures last night
voted against steps which are necessary
to protect the nhs and to protect lives
thank you uh mr speaker the government
is taking a balanced and a proportionate
approach uh to dealing with uh the
pandemic and the uh the house voted
through uh plan b i think with
conservative votes mr speaker and we
will continue uh with the massive
booster rollout to which he is a uh to
which is a a late convert uh since
friday when i decided that we had to
accelerate the booster program in view
of the data about omicron we've cut the
timetable in half
mr speaker monday was the biggest
vaccination monday in the history of
this country and yesterday was the
second biggest vaccination achievement
by the nhs ever more than 500 000 jabs
delivered and the campaign continues to
grow i want to thank absolutely
everybody involved i want to thank all
the british public for coming forward to
get boosted now
mr speaker we all hope that combined
with the booster program plan b will be
sufficient to prevent the nhs from being
overwhelmed
nobody wants to see further restrictions
but the prime minister has quite rightly
not ruled anything out
so can i take this opportunity to make
clear to the prime minister that if
further votes are needed to save lives
and protect the nhs labour mps will
follow my leadership and we will always
put the national interest first
can i ask the prime minister to get his
house in order so he can say the same
about the members behind him
[Applause]
uh yes uh mr speaker if further measures
are needed as the house will understand
if further regulation is needed of
course this house uh will have a further
say as for following his leadership mr
speaker uh they wibbled wobbled over
plan b they wibble wobbled over
quarantine and if we listened if we
listened to him mr speaker uh we
wouldn't even have the vaccine rolling
because we would have remained in the
european medicines agency
and we wouldn't it's true and we
wouldn't have opened up on july the 19th
mr speaker we would have remained in
lockdown that's the reality mr speaker
mr speaker let me put that straight back
in his box
the labour party showed the leadership
yesterday that the prime minister lacked
if
mr speaker if it wasn't for labor votes
his government
wouldn't have been able to introduce
vital health measures we need to save
lives and protect the nhs so weak is his
leadership
his own mps were wrong to vote against
basic public health measures
but i can understand why they're angry
with him
after all the health secretary said this
summer that relaxations of restrictions
were irreversible
they weren't
only last week the government or order
order i've been tempted by both of you a
little bit too much think it's christmas
that's the only reason you're going to
remain primarily kirsten
mr speaker only last week the government
was saying plan b measures were not
required they are
just like the rail revolution for the
north no one will have to sell their
homes for social care just like no tax
rises it's over promise after over
promise
until reality catches up
does the prime minister understand why
his own mps no longer trust him
mr speaker you know there he goes again
he comes to this house pompously
claiming that he wants to rise above uh
party politics and support the efforts
of the nation in delivering the vaccine
rollout and then and then he talks
endlessly about party politics in place
of political gains i think what the
people in this country can see is as a
result of what this government has done
uh with the decisions we've taken the
tough decisions that we've taken to
deliver the which he ducked mr speaker
to deliver the fastest vaccine rollout
in europe and now the fastest booster
rollout we now have mr speaker the
fastest growing economy in the g7 and
more jobs today more jobs today 500 000
more jobs today than there were when the
pandemic began that is conservative
government in action mr speaker we
deliver they complain
[Applause]
mr speaker the only person undermining
public confidence is sitting right now
here's the problem his mps are wrong to
vote against basic public health
measures
but they are not wrong to distrust him
last week the conservative member for
the forest of dean
asked
why should people at home listening to
the prime minister do things that people
working in downing street are not
prepared to do tory mp the conservative
member for shipley last week asked the
prime minister
can he give me any reason
at all why i should shouldn't tell my
constituents to treat these rules the
same way that downey street treated
these rules last year
now the prime minister had a week to
come up with a good answer
has he done so
[Applause]
mr speaker the answer is very very clear
and it's there in what the public are
doing uh mr speaker because they can see
they can see that the government is
getting on with deliver delivering on
their priorities not just on the economy
mr speaker but above all on delivering
the fastest booster rollout in europe
and uh you know he likes to he like he's
fond of these european comparisons mr
speaker but we've done almost double the
percentage of any other european country
uh we've we've boosted we've boosted 86
of the over 80s in this country 91
of those aged 75 uh to 79 that is an
astonishing achievement and i think that
is what the people of this country are
focused on mr speaker and rather than
rather than the partisan trivia that he
continually raises when frankly when
frankly uh he has a case to answer
himself
[Music]
i think that's no he hasn't come up with
a good answer
for weeks now
he claims that no rules were broken he
claims he didn't know what was happening
in his own house last christmas
i don't believe him
his mps don't believe him and nor to the
british public
he's taking the public for falls
and it's becoming dangerous
because from today
anyone who tests positive for
coronavirus faces a second christmas in
isolation
it will be heartbreaking for families
across the country
the message from the government has to
be
we know that following the rules won't
be easy this christmas
but it is necessary
can the prime minister not see
that he has no hope of regaining the
moral authority to deliver that
difficult message
if he cannot be straight with the
british public about the rule breaking
in downing street last christmas
mr speaker i've repeatedly answered that
question uh before and and uh and as he
knows a report is being uh delivered uh
to me by the cabin etc into exactly uh
what went on he might explain why there
are pictures of him coughing beer mr
speaker
[Applause]
in a way i mean we haven't heard we
haven't i think what the british public
wants us all to do frankly and what they
want us all to do is focus on focus on
the matter in hand and continue to
deliver the vaccine rollout in the way
that we are and i think it is an
absolutely fantastic thing that people
are now coming forward in the way that
we are the way that they are 45 percent
of people over 18 have now had a vaccine
mr speaker and i'm very and i thank i
thank our amazing staff i thank the nhs
i thank all the gps i thank the gps and
we how we are well you blocked that you
blocked the investment in there
they wouldn't vote for it they wouldn't
vote for investment in our nhs mr
speaker they wouldn't they wouldn't do
it i i thank them for what they're doing
i can tell the house that uh we're now
speeding things up uh by allowing people
to avoid the 15-minute delay after
they've been vaccinated which i hope
will encourage even more people to come
forward
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker the virus is spreading once
again and lives and livelihoods are at
risk
the british public are looking for a
prime minister with the trust and the
authority to lead britain through the
crisis
instead we're burdened with the worst
possible prime minister at the worst
possible time
they're shouting now where were they in
the lobby last night
[Applause]
his own mps have had enough
they won't defend him they won't turn up
to support him and if he proposes them
they won't vote for basic public health
measures
so at this time of national effort the
labour party stood up shown the
leadership that the prime minister can't
and put the health and security of the
british people first
this is silly because i can't hear the
question i will hear the quest
i don't think we need any more help from
this front bench i'm just doing this
corner first before i come back
can i just say i understand it's the
last pm cues and we're going to be
coming back in the new year but i do
need to hear the question and it may
take a long time but i will hear it so
please i want to get through questions i
want you all to get away for christmas
at this stage you won't dear stammer
mr speaker the primary is so weak that
without labor votes last night vital
public health measures wouldn't have got
through
but this country can't
this is not true
it's not true
he's so socially distant from the truth
he thinks that that's not true i don't
know where to start
we better press on we can't go on with
the prime minister who's too weak to
lead
so will the prime minister take time
this christmas to look in the mirror and
ask himself whether he has the trust and
authority to lead this country
mr speaker
thank you very much mr speaker
we won that uh vote last night with
conservative votes as i as i told the
house
i i respect i respect the feelings and i
respect the anxieties uh that colleagues
have about of course i do i respect and
understand the anxieties the legitimate
anxieties that colleagues have about uh
restrictions on their liberty but i
believe uh and on the liberty of people
but i believe that the approach that
we're taking is balanced and
proportionate and right for this country
and let me tell you mr speaker let me
tell the house about something he talks
about leadership some of the decisions
the tough decisions that i've had to
take i had to decide to stay out of the
european ventilator scheme so we had our
own ventilator challenge
which he then he then ridiculously
attacked i decided to go ahead ahead of
the rest of europe ahead of the rest of
europe with the vaccine roll out mr
speaker which would have been impossible
if we listened to him i decided to go
ahead with opening up our society and
our economy on july the 19th which he
opposed mr speaker which he opposed and
frankly uh if we listen to him never
forget we would not now have the fastest
economic growth of the g7 it's because
it's because we took those courageous
steps mr speaker that we now have 500
000 more people in work now than there
were when the pandemic began and
yesterday i saw 1.2 million job
vacancies mr speaker that is what
conservative governments do they create
employment they create business
opportunities and by all and above all
mr speaker we vaccinate they vacillate
they they jabber we jab they play party
politics mr speaker and we get on with
the job
i'm amazed
i'm absolutely amazed that some of you
wanted to catch my eye
obviously you don't thanks for that it's
making my life easier
so don't be shocked when i wasn't going
to put you in for that special question
let's come to the man of the moment dr
liam fox
thank you mr speaker as we look forward
to 2022 one of the dates that stands out
for me is the 21st of march which will
be international down syndrome day
in thanking the government for the
support and indeed thanking all parties
in the house for the support for the
down syndrome bill can i ask the prime
minister if he will give his personal
commitment to ensure that we get that
bill on the statute before international
down syndrome day when we will be the
first country in the world to do so we
talk about global britain it can't just
be about trade and diplomacy it must
also be about values wouldn't that be a
great place for britain to start
[Music]
[Applause]
my right honourable friend is a
wonderful campaigner on this issue he's
completely right about down syndrome
people they can have poorer health
outcomes that this bill i know does aim
to improve uh a life outcomes for uh for
people with dien's syndrome and we are
pleased to support it and we will do
whatever we can to ensure the prompt
progress of this bill
we now come to the leader of the smp ian
blackburn
thank you mr speaker can i can i wish
you
it's not a part of mine
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker can i wish you all
your staff all members in the house a
merry christmas and a good new year when
it comes and
send my thanks to those in the front
line on emergency service and armed
forces for everything that they have
done to get us through this year
mr speaker
the public understands the threat that
omicron poses to all our people and to
our nhs
but we saw from last night's vote
the tories might be privileged enough to
live in denial about this danger
but the rest of us have the
responsibility to live in the real world
that means increasing public health
measures and increasing financial
support for businesses and workers
the scottish government
is delivering 100 million pounds from
our fixed budget to support businesses
but we all know
that more is needed
yesterday
the uk government put out a press
release saying that new financial
support was coming
but last night the treasury u-turn say
no new money was available so prime
minister which is it is there any new
money to support businesses or was it
all just smoke and mirrors once again
yeah yeah
i i'm grateful to the to the right
honourable gentleman and i i share some
of the points that he made about the
importance of uh being vigilant about
omicron i think it's it's good that he
uh that he that he set that out i think
it's important that uh we continue to
work with the scottish administration as
we do uh to help over everybody uh
through it there is uh more money as he
knows uh through barnet consequentials
there are also uh further powers under
uh under the existing devolutionary
settlement for uh the scottish
administration to to raise money uh if
it uh chooses to uh they they have that
option but we will we will of course uh
continue uh with the discussions with
the scottish uh administration
ian blackford mr speaker that simply
wasn't an answer and it really just does
confirm it's all smoking mirrors there
was no new money for scotland once again
the prime minister can't trust a word
that this prime minister says dodgy
dealings on renovations and his distant
relationship with the truth all of it
has left them weak
last night
this uk government
struggled to get measures through this
house that scotland has had for months
a prime minister who can't do what is
needed to protect the public is no prime
minister at all
mr speaker nobody wants further
restrictions
but scotland can't afford to be
hamstrung if the prime minister can't
act because he's got 99 problems behind
him so will he give the evolved
governments the powers and financial
support that we need to protect our
people
uh mr speaker i think we need a bit of
bigger ways to contain the synthetic
indignation of the right honourable uh a
gentleman quite frankly uh if i can just
i can just tell him uh that there are
the powers the scottish administration
has the powers but what we've also done
and what we've also done mr speaker is a
record uh settlement a record settlement
settlement uh for scotland 41 uh billion
pounds but i i in all friendship to with
the government
who i'm actually quite cordial with
behind the scenes and mr speaker we will
work with the scottish government to
make sure that we get through this thing
together
thank you mr speaker
stroke
is
the leading cause of adult disability in
the united kingdom it's the fourth
largest killer we've made much progress
but regressively in the last couple of
years key treatments like thrombectomy
thrombolysis and timely interventions in
hospital have actually stalled and gone
backwards
in particular most stroke survivors do
not
receive less than half the recommended
levels of rehabilitation something which
the prime minister knows my own family
have experienced can we urgently look to
upgrade the very good national stroke
plan into a fully fledged national
strategy for stroke with a minister
responsible for it and a dedicated team
of officials in the department to roll
that out
i want to thank my right my right
honourable friend for that question i
know his uh uh he and i have discussed
before his own uh personal reasons for
caring uh so much about this issue i i
understand and i sympathize uh deeply uh
with uh with what he's saying and that's
why uh one of the reasons why uh i want
to make sure that we do invest enough in
in this there are 20 integrated uh
stroke networks in england already what
we want to do is uh increase their
capacity uh by about tenfold uh mr
speaker very happy to make sure that he
has the right uh meeting with the
relevant minister to discuss uh the
matter but that's why it's so important
uh that we invest now in our nhs uh in
the way that we are and what a pity uh
that that essential measure could not be
supported uh by the party opposite let
me swept
speaker the prime minister's actions
over the last number of months have
absolutely eroded public confidence at
the worst possible time in a public
health crisis excusing rule breaking by
his own mps ignoring rule breaking in
his own house he can't even lead tory
mps to vote for his public health
guidance how does he expect to lead
anybody else surely now it is time mr
speaker for him to do the right thing
the only thing left him to respond
restore public confidence and resign
no mr speaker i'm going to get on with
protecting the public of this country
and making sure
that we get through this pandemic
together as one united kingdom uh mr
speaker and making sure that we protect
uh trade uh between great britain and
northern ireland in the way that i know
he would want it protected
alders thank you very much mr speaker in
east anglia there are on the one hand
tremendous opportunities in such sectors
as low carbon energy and sustainable
fishing and yet on the other hand
significant challenges with deep pockets
of deprivation particularly in coastal
communities i acknowledge the investment
that has been made but there is a
concern locally that the government has
yet to comprehend the scale of the
opportunity that our region has to be a
global exemplar in new and revitalized
industries and in doing so bring
transformative and long-term benefits to
local people
will my right honourable friend meet
with other east african mps and myself
so that together we can put in place a
strategy to realize the full potential
of the east of england
[Applause]
yes mr speaker but i i also i also want
to say uh that i understand completely
the massive opportunity uh that exists
in and the potential that exists in
those coastal uh communities and uh and
that is why we're investing 120 million
pounds already in five new town deals
including uh for lestaft uh mr speaker
and uh i'm sure that my rather friend
the secretary of state for for leveling
up uh will want to be uh taking his
points on board as we uh bring forward
the leveling up uh white paper in the
new year
thank you mr speaker does the prime
minister believe that is the damage
being caused by brexit his litany of
broken promises his condoning of
conservative party corruption or just
simply his complicity in lockdown
busting
christmas
parties and quizzes which has caused the
public to so dramatically so rapidly
lose faith in his leadership yeah
mr speaker what i observe is it actually
it was our freedom from the rules of the
european union uh that enabled that
enabled us to deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in in europe uh that has
enabled us uh to have the fastest
economic growth uh in the g7 and that is
of massive benefit to each and every one
of his constituents and i think he
should acknowledge that point aura
thank you mr speaker one of the
significant achievements of this
government is the work it's done with
local authorities to tackle rough
sleeping five years ago 36 people were
sleeping rough in the newbury area this
christmas west berkshire council have
reduced that to zero
but they can only sustain that success
with the help of additional support
services to tackle the complex causes of
homelessness what action will the
government take through its new 10-year
drug strategy to intercept the link
between addiction and life on the
streets
my honorable friend is completely right
to draw the link between uh drug
addiction and and rough sleeping and
that's why our drug strategy is so
absolutely vital uh for tackling uh this
problem i also want to thank local
councils mr speaker uh and everybody
involved in the the everyone in uh
campaign uh i think that homelessness
and rough sleeping are a blight and a
disgrace a shame uh for our society and
i'm i'm proud to say uh that levels are
falling our rough sleeping uh snapshot
shows levels have fallen uh 43
uh since 2017 though uh clearly as we
come out of the of the pandemic uh in
the next year or so we must make sure
that we continue uh to reduce rough
sleeping it means an absolute priority
for this government bentley
mr speaker
with the emergence of the omicron
variant and a raising number of carving
infections more and more people are
being asked to self-isolate to stay at
home to look after isolating children
i've been contacted by people in
keradigion who have been excluded from
isolation support payments as they are
not in receipt of benefits or above the
weekly earnings threshold will the prime
minister act urgently to increase
statutory sick pay which currently
stands at a mere 96 pounds 35 a week so
the people in this position do not have
to choose between following public
health regulations or putting food on
the table
i i thank you very much and i i
understand the difficulty some families
will will find themselves in we want to
look after everybody throughout the the
pandemic and that's why we've done
things like lift the living wage in the
way we have increased the uh the funds
available for for child care uh but also
made sure that the councils have an
extra hardship fund of half a billion
pounds to help families of the kind that
he's describing through this winter
shakira
thank you very much mr speaker following
confirmation of the the crew to
manchester leg of hs2 the olsen factory
and crew winning a hs2 rolling stock
contract and crew's long history at the
heart of our railway industry does the
prime minister agree with me that crew
is a strong contender for the
headquarters of great british railways
and can he tell me when the process to
choose the location the new hq will
start
well mr speaker i think my brief says
here i'll be very careful what i say
i have no doubt that crew is a strong uh
contender uh but further details of the
competition will be announced in the in
the coming uh weeks uh mr speaker and i
know that expressions of interest uh
from places such as crew will be very
welcome
linda maria
thank you mr speaker after inquest
verdicts on the 97 people who died in
the hillsborough disaster of unlawful
killing
the right honourable gentleman stood for
election to this house on a manifesto
that included legislating to introduce a
public advocate
why then is his government repeatedly
blocking my public advocate bill which
has cross-party support
and will prevent families bereaved by
public disasters from ever again having
to endure what the hillsborough families
have had to cope with over the last 32
years is it an oversight or yet another
broken promise
i i thank the the the right honourable
lady and no we do recognize the
importance of putting the bereaved and
the bereaved of of hillsborough at the
heart of an investigation uh and we
think that in certain circumstances
funding uh may be uh
available for uh a representation for
the bereaved of public inquiry uh or
interest we are considering to her point
we are considering what steps uh should
be taken i will ensure that she has uh a
meeting with the relevant minister uh in
the uh in the relevant department in the
home office as soon as possible
mr speaker
as we see
russian forces massing on the ukrainian
border
can we be reminded that russia is also
continuing cyber attacks attempted
assassinations using gas as a political
weapon holding illegally territory in
the crimea in georgia
intimidating the west and attempting
interfering in western elections
how much does the government understand
that president putin is conducting a
hybrid war against the west and how is
the government responding to it
i i thank my right honourable friend and
he i'm afraid he is absolutely right in
what he in what he says and he's also
right to stress the particular urgency
of the situation in uh he's right in
what he says about hybrid warfare and
all the other uh interventions but there
is a particular uh crisis that we face
on the border with ukraine where russian
troops have been massing for some time
as the house knows and i uh told
president putin on on monday what uh
i think everybody in the g7 uh and and
more widely is agreed that if russia
were so rash so mad as to engage in an
invasion of uh sovereign territory of
ukraine then there would be
an extremely
tough package of economic sanctions
mounted by
our allies mounted by the uk and our
friends around the world uh there would
also of course uh be support uh for
ukraine uh there would inevitably be the
buildup of nato forces in the uh
periphery
regions and i as i told president putin
i believe any such action would be
catastrophic uh not just for russia and
for ukraine but for the for the world
and mr speaker
thank you mr speaker
the prime minister made an address to
the nation on sunday on covid booster
jabs and he said every eligible adult
will have the chance to get the booster
before the new year
roughly two weeks away
however the health secretary and our
national health leaders have said
otherwise
we know that those who deliver our
health service were not adequately
consulted the infrastructure to deliver
was not prepared
isn't this going to be yet another
broken promised prime minister
mr speaker yes this is a
massive national effort
yes it will be incredibly hard to
achieve but do i believe that our nhs
our gps our volunteers can do it yes i
do mr speaker and i think that's the
spirit that's the spirit in which she
and the whole house should approach it
and rather than taking that that
approach mr speaker can i advise all uh
the labor benches uh and all colleagues
around this house to tell our
constituents to get boosted now
tom touga
speaker i very much welcome my right
honourable friend's answer to a question
just a moment ago and his emphasis on
global britain and partnership in
standing up to autocracies will he
therefore share the concern that i have
about the reports i've just got from the
foreign office that there is a staff cut
of 10
across the board
how is this compatible with global
britain
[Music]
uh
mr speaker we are investing massively in
overseas aid we're investing massively
uh 10 10 billion pounds a year in in
overseas aid uh this country is spending
i think we are the biggest spender in
europe overseas 54 billion if you look
at what we're doing on aid on the
foreign office on defence we are the
biggest spender over the biggest spender
on overseas activities of any country in
europe and i i i know he's an expert on
foreign affairs uh mr speaker but i can
tell him that the recent information
that has trickled into his ears is i'm
assured by my right honourable friend
the foreign secretary fake news
ruth gabriel
thank you mr speaker transport for
london faces serious financial
difficulties solely due to the pandemic
causing the collapse in fair's income
the emergency kovic funding to tfl
expires the day after
tomorrow prior to the pandemic the mayor
of london spent four years improving
tfl's finances
[Applause]
there will be a nightmare
there will be a nightmare in the moment
can i just say we want to get through
the questions i was hoping to get some
extra people in you're not helping me do
so
come on in ruth cabral thank you mr
speaker prior to the pandemic the mayor
of london sadiq khan spent four years
improving tfl's finances after
his predecessor inexplicit inexplicably
bargained away tfl 700 million annual
government grant
by
by failing
by
by failing to meet the mayor on
extending the emergency covid grant this
government is putting the city's economy
and environment at risk rail companies
have had additional support
[Music]
[Applause]
will the pm instructor
will the pm instruct silent shops to
meet the mayor immediately so that buses
and tubes can continue to keep london
moving from friday
mr speaker this happens to be one of the
subjects i probably know more about than
anybody else
in this house
and i can i can i can tell her uh that
uh when i was mayor and run and i was
chairman of transport for london uh we
had our finances uh in balance because i
ran a responsible affairs policy uh when
i when i left the mayoralty uh we had
crossrail in surplus and we had uh we
had our reserves in services what
happened actually was that the labour
mayor of london embarked on a reckless
unfunded affairs policy a reckless
unfunded affairs policy that uh cutting
feds recklessly so to leave a huge black
hole in transport for london's finances
and yes mr speaker we have the greatest
capitals
i'm not going to dissent from that and
we will of course help uh the stricken
uh labor anymore
in any way that we can but blame lies
fairly and squarely with city hall
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
i'd like to wish all of our constituents
for all across the countries a merry
christmas in the safe 2022.
what matters to my sedge fair
constituents though is jobs jobs jobs
would the pm con join me in
congratulating natashi and olsen
securing the hs2 rolling stock car
direct which is a tremendous vote of
confidence in the people of newton
neglect in sedgefield and could i ask
him to encourage the secretary of state
for transport to confirm that the
feasibility street for fourier station
approved his earliest convenience so we
can get on with leveling up building
back better for fourier bishop midland
sedgefield and the conference
yes i i thank my i thank my honorable
friend who is a great advocate for
sedgefield and for his constituents and
and for levelling up i congratulate
hitachi in alstom uh on securing the hs2
stock order and the proponents of the
ferry hill station for completing the
initial business case uh for the scheme
and mr speaker this is part of the 96
billion pound investment that we're
making in our railway infrastructure the
biggest in a hundred years dwarfing
anything that the labour party has ever
embarked on and we will get on with
uniting and leveling up across our
country
thank you mr speaker
i'm i'm sure the prime minister would
like to thank me for assisting him as he
was unaware of last year's i've been
kept in the dark about last year's
festivities with my assistants in
lighting the christmas tree in downing
street this year unlike the prime
minister i am not in the dark as to what
my staff are doing this year we are
serving
and delivering over a thousand hampers
and gifts to families across bonds east
to make sure they get across swansea
that they get a christmas willis prime
minister please join me in
congratulating thanking everyone
involved and everyone deserves your
christmas and if you would like to come
and like to treat in my constituency i'm
not sure whether there's one available
here
can i say that's one of the nicest
things somebody said to me from the
benches of it for a long time
and mr speaker and i i i i i i do want
to thank and congratulate everybody uh
in her constituency who's uh helping to
bring a hampers uh to those who need it
this christmas it's a wonderful thing
thank you mr speaker
my thoughts and i'm sure the thoughts of
the whole house are with those who loved
star hobson who was brutally murdered by
a monster whilst starr's evil mother
allowed this to happen in keithley
the court heard that numerous referrals
were made to bradford council's
children's services months in advance of
star's murder but they were not taken
seriously in fact the case was closed
the prime minister will be aware that
this is the latest of a long list of
failings at bradford council's
children's services where political
correctness appears to have been put
before the welfare of children
i have no confidence in bradford
council's leadership to deliver
children's services
and since the death of star i am pleased
that the government has sent in a
commissioner to over
sorry i'm very bothered with going into
sub-judiciary it is very very serious
and i don't want to cause a real problem
i would say for the premise if we could
answer without getting any further
details i think we've gone a little bit
too far into what the case is at the
moment prime minister
mr speaker i'm grateful for for your
direction i i would just want to say
that i think the whole house will
it will once again be filled with
incredulity at the the cruelty of people
who could perpetrate a child killing
like this
but also
sadness and bewilderment that it could
not have been uh prevented and uh this
uh
we will uh appoint as you as as my own
friend knows appoint a commissioner to
assess uh the relevant council
bradford's capability and capacity uh to
improve uh on their findings and they
will report on their their handling they
will report in january uh but uh this
will also feed in uh to the report that
we've uh commissioned on the death of
arthur labinjo hughes and i say to those
who are responsible uh in the in the
authorities concerned that we will not
hesitate to remove service control if
that is what is necessary to drive the
improvements uh that we need to see
that comes to the end we're going to go
to your huge can i just wish everybody a
wonderful christmas and let's have a
peaceful new year to everybody thank you
yeah
well prime minister's questions they're
coming to an end uh when sakia stalmer
basically
honed in on the prime minister's
integrity and whether he could be
trusted to run the country saying he's
socially distanced from the truth with
me uh
beth rigby what do you make of that
well kierstahler uh very critical there
of the prime minister he sees the
vulnerability he went in on attack
he told the pm he had to get his house
in order so that mps will support him if
necessary measures
are needed in the coming weeks and he
tried to drive a wedge between the prime
minister in his back benches by being
quite
pointed about uh those 100 uh that did
rebel reiterating what he said last
night really which is that this is a
prime minister who now uh can't perform
the basic functions of keeping people
safe let's go back to the conference
an urgent question about preparations
for reopening schools
in january great concerns about
ventilation and the safety of pupils and
teachers during the pandemic robert
halford of course is disabled while he's
asking his questions sitting down thank
you mr speaker again
very grateful to you for granting this
urgent question on day when the school's
minister is out of town
mr speaker the government are committed
to ensuring schools open in january as
normal the classroom is the very best
place for children and young people's
development and we are incredibly
grateful to teachers and all education
staff for all they have done to maintain
face-to-face learning protecting
education continues to be our absolute
priority
the government has taken action to help
manage the omicron variant and the prime
minister has already announced that we
are turbo charging our kovid 19 booster
program
to offer every adult in england a
vaccine by the end of the year to
protect people from the omicron variant
we have set out clear plans for school
openings in january including on-site
lateral flow testing on return for
secondary school students continued
regular testing at home for the
education and child care sectors and a
comprehensive contingency framework to
manage outbreaks
as of first december over 95.2 million
tests have been completed across all
education settings and the government
has made over one hundred million pounds
of funding available to education
settings to support with costs
schools and education settings have a
range of measures in place to manage
covered and reduce transmission
including regular testing additional
hygiene practices increasing ventilation
and procedures for managing confirmed
cases
from tuesday the 14th of december a new
national daily testing of covid's of
contact policy was introduced
this means that young people and fully
vaccinated adults who are identified as
a close contact of someone with covid
can take an nhs rapid lateral flow test
every day for seven days and continue to
attend their setting as normal unless
they have a positive result
we also recommend all the students and
staff to wear face coverings in communal
areas and have supported education
settings to improve ventilation
the government committed to delivering
300 thousand co2 monitors by the end of
this term we have already delivered
329 000 with over 99 of eligible
settings receiving monitors
every child age 12 and over is eligible
to receive the vaccine and we want to
encourage all children and parents to
take up this offer as soon as possible
if they haven't already it is vital
though that all of us including parents
carers teachers and everyone working in
education goes out as soon as they
possibly can to get their boosted job to
protect the nhs our way of life and to
protect education
thank you mr speaker for granting the
question now despite the heroic efforts
of teachers and support staff in harlow
and around the country who've worked
tirelessly to keep students learning
the four horsemen of the education
apocalypse have been galloping towards
our young people in the form of a
widening attainment gap an epidemic of
mental health problems a rise in
safeguarding hazards and a loss of life
chances and we know the attainment gap
between rich and poor students is
getting worse and children being
referred to mental health support
services has increased by 62
we know the damage that school closures
bring a hundred thousand ghost children
are missing entirely almost entirely
from the school world
and yesterday the dfe released new
figures showing that over 230 000
children were not in school for coveted
related incidents
the government stated they want to keep
schools open
but what is the plan in order to do so
what measures are being taken to ensure
that should education staff be required
to isolate there's a network of supply
teachers ready to step in
is additional funding being made
available to provide adequate
ventilation in schools
the health sector is right to say that
we should protect the nhs but why can't
the department of education not say we
have to protect our children's futures
why don't we have adverts about that
what mental health support is being
given to our young people affected by
the pandemic what assessment is being
made of the impact of lost learning for
students in critical exam years there's
a nationwide campaign for an army of nhs
volunteers but not for education
why is a similar army of retired
teachers or offset inspectors not being
recruited to support schools struggling
to cope with staffing requirements can
we not have
the same vision the same passion the
same resource provision for the
education service as we do for the
national health service
despite the government's assurances it
seems to me we are moving sadly towards
de facto school closures i urge
ministers to prove otherwise
thank you mr speaker and i thank my
right honourable friend the chair of the
education select committee for his
question i know how much this uh subject
means to him and uh i'm sure he'll
recognize how much it uh matters to
everyone in the department for education
um we are absolutely clear that the best
place for school children is in school
that the best thing for school children
is to have face-to-face teaching
and as the secretary of state said at
the weekend he will do everything in his
power to ensure that that continues
we
we have a range of work uh underway in
response to this fast-moving situation
um currently i believe uh there are uh
14 uh hospitalizations uh from obercron
um that uh the the rate of doubling of
cases is about every two days
um at the weekend uh the secretary of
state was on the andrew martial where he
said i think that uh about a third of um
of cases in london were omicron that
number is already um over 50 percent so
to deal with this we um
we have set about uh four things uh
testing
vaccination
ventilation
and hygiene
and these are the ways in which we will
absolutely uh back schools to make sure
that um on in classroom teaching can
continue
we are recommending that at the start of
next term
all secondary school school pupils uh
will be tested right at the start of
term and we are um offering a small
amount of flexibility for the time at
which uh schools can go back in order to
make sure this testing can go place we
take place we are offering additional
funding to make sure that that this
testing is available
i can reassure the house
that
schools have and will have all the
testing facilities that they require on
vaccination uh six out of ten uh 17 16
17 year olds have already been jabbed
and over 80 percent of all
everybody in the population age 12 and
over uh has received at least two jabs
and this is a remarkable achievement
made possible by uh our world leading
vaccine uh procurement and vaccine uh
rollout
we are we have also seen um 99 as i
mentioned earlier 99
of schools receive a co2 monitor and
schools are running um very
comprehensive and advanced hygiene
programs wherever
the key uh to our success in the battle
against omicron will be the booster
programme this is a national mission of
utmost importance and severity the
government is throwing the kitchen sink
at making sure that before schools get
back mr speaker
all adults will have had the chance to
have their booster you know this is the
way forward this is how we maximize our
chances for making sure that our
children get the world-class education
they deserve
we come to shadow minister stephen
yeah yeah thank you mr speaker i firstly
take the opportunity to thank school
staff governors parents and pupils
across the country for their dedication
and hard work during a year of unrivaled
difficulties but the government's
complacency means we are now in a race
against time to protect children's
health and education as the omicron
variant spreads
yesterday's absence figures show 235 000
children now out of school due to covid
up 13
in the last fortnight an average of 175
000 children have been out of school
every day this term
this ongoing disruption to education
comes on top of the average of 115 days
of in-person school that pupils missed
between march 2020 and july 21.
mr speaker the government has serious
questions to answer about why further
steps have not been taken to reduce the
spread of covid amongst peoples
we know vaccination and ventilation are
vital to these efforts but ministers are
falling short on both
sage first highlighted the importance of
ventilation in schools in may 2020 but
19 months on the government has failed
to act on their advice
mr speaker there is literally a problem
that the government could have fixed
while the sun was shining instead their
failure to get vaccination measures in
place is pushing schools to open windows
despite plummeting temperatures while
school energy bills rocket
therefore will the minister immediately
publish interim findings of the bradford
pilot of air purifiers and work with all
schools to implement recommendations
from this
on vaccinations nationally we find that
less than half of 12 to 15 year olds
have had a vaccine
ministers missed their own target to
offer everyone in that age group a jab
by october and have not set a new one
yet perhaps most concerningly the weekly
number of jobs administered to 12 to 15
year olds has dropped by 80 percent
since half term
will the mr commit to a vaccine deliver
a vaccine guarantee so all young people
can get their jab by the end of the
christmas holidays
will he also set up what steps he will
take to rapidly ramp up the rollout
will he adopt labour's calls for a clear
targeted communications campaign to
parents on the benefits of the
vaccination
access to pop-up and walk-in clinics and
the mobilization of volunteers and
retired clinicians
mr speaker staff children and parents
are now entering into their third school
year of disruption
time and time again this government's
failure to plan ahead has left children
bearing the brunt of the pandemic
ministers must stop treating them as an
afterthought and act now to avoid chaos
next term yeah
minister
thank you mr speaker look this um i i'd
like to
join uh the honourable gentleman in here
in his remarks uh about uh schools and
school staff we understand that they
have in extremely difficult conditions
over the past 18 months worked
enormously hard
to uh to do the best for uh do the best
for children i think that um it's
important to recognize that the work
that they have done uh throughout has
has made it possible that we are uh now
in a position where we have um
good and improving rates of vaccination
we have good ventilation we have good
hygiene and we have good testing in
schools and as i made clear to my answer
to the right honourable gentleman from
harlow
these are uh the key um uh recipes for
for
making sure that schools are in the best
position they can be but the national um
solution to the omicron variant must be
and can only be
boosted
and that's why we need as many people as
possible to come forward uh in the
course of the next few weeks and take up
the invitation government uh and the the
enormous effort that we are putting in
to making sure that vaccine centers are
available near people that there are
walk-ins
and
that people will be able to uh to step
forward and take the protection well
we're going to stay with this statement
on plans for schools in the new year uh
in the face of the coveted pandemic
but uh that is all from our coverage of
prime minister's questions for today
coming up next guy news with jane secker
that the disgraceful campaign of
intimidation
[Music]
[Music]
you